you
and next up on book TV this is our
afterwords program Republican strategist
Roger stone talks about the 2016
presidential election and president
Donald Trump in his new book the making
of the president 2016 mr. stone is
interviewed by Susan Ferruccio the
Washington examiner's chief
congressional correspondent
welcome Roger stone author of the brand
new book the making of the president
2016 this is your fifth book but a
really special one for you because you
know the subject so well and have known
for decades so I'm gonna start with my
first question how do you think
President Trump is doing I think he's
doing fine in view of the fact that he's
had no honeymoon which has been pretty
traditional for our presidents no two or
three weeks of goodwill from the other
party and that his election was such a
shock to the political system he's
sticking to his agenda which is the key
thing I think he's making progress on
issues and all these other contra temps
about his Twitter feed and so on I
really think that's a sideshow that the
voters not too interested in the Twitter
feed though has become a big part of his
presidency the media focuses on it
becomes a subject on talk shows it's
almost you know as big a part of his
presidency as is when he takes to the
podium how do you consider that in the
grand scheme of things in terms of his
success as a president going forward do
you think this will help him could
potentially hurt him if you were on his
staff would you advise them to cool it
on the Twitter or do you think maybe
it's a good thing it's his ability to
communicate directly to the voters
without the filter of the mainstream
media or even the alternative media so I
think it's an extremely valuable tool as
he likes to say it's like owning a
newspaper without the debt you can reach
16 million people in a flash so I would
urge him to keep tweeting because I
think it is a valuable tool the
mainstream media Nashes their teeth
about it because it allows him to
communicate direct I don't think they
like that they like to interpret that
said I do think that he is going to be
Donald Trump he's not going to change
this whole idea that he is going to
become more presidential he could become
more diplomatic I don't think that's how
he got elected people like him because
he's blunt because he's genuine because
he's uncoated unscripted what you see is
what you get that's what we have elected
but I will go back to
referring to your book will you talk
about your departure from the campaign
in part because you differed with
strategy look like you wanted a little
bit more discipline maybe a little less
of trumping Trump and more campaign
discipline how does that you know how do
you take that and square it with your
view now do you think that he does need
more discipline now in the way that you
felt was needed during the campaign
doesn't really matter what I think the
truth is I left the campaign but never
stopped being a Trump supporter or a
cheerleader for a couple reasons one my
book the Clintons war on women was about
to publish and I didn't want anyone to
say oh that's a Trump project or a Trump
funded project or a Trump directed
project because it wasn't secondarily
and I was wrong about this I wanted him
to run a more traditional campaign in
terms of the traditional tools of
campaigning polling analytics paid
advertising and so on he eschewed all
those things I didn't think you could
win doing that he was right I was wrong
he's a phenomena unto himself I'm not
sure would work for any other candidate
but it did work for Donald Trump well in
your book you describe him as using that
unconventional approach to have this
unprecedented victory and as you said it
was different than the approach you were
talking about can you talk about in your
book and how you describe how he was
able to overcome not having a
traditional approach yet still winning
in these states that Republicans haven't
been able to win and where he didn't was
spend the same amount of money as the
Democrats or even the Republican machine
when he was running in the primary in
your estimation how was it that he was
able to get around the need for all
those traditional approaches this
election was different than any other
presidential election I've been involved
in and I this would be my tenth
presidential campaign this was the
election in which the tipping point was
finally reached in terms of the
mainstream media losing their monopoly
on the dissemination of political
information obviously in the 60s when
there was only three networks the
destruction of Barry Goldwater was
pretty easy all three networks chimed in
and
good old Barry was done a warmonger a
maniac a lunatic of course later when he
gets back to the Senate he becomes quite
revered in this election the tipping
point had been reached largely I think
because of technological reasons meaning
people now getting their news on their
handheld device no longer getting it
from a television set and therefore the
mainstream media the three networks the
two cable networks really lost their own
their ratings start to drop and more and
more voters are getting their
information from alternative sources
some of them conservative alternative
sources some of them just alternative
sources so yes info wars.com Breitbart
Daily Caller townhall those are all
important and Trump I think realizes
this when nobody else does the other key
factor is for the first time ever I
think voters begin to realize that big
media is in bed with big government and
the big establishment that the three
networks and the two cable outlets are
reinforcing the narrative of the
mainstream media and voters for the
first time are skeptical used to be if
you saw something on TV it must be true
now I think the opposite is true you see
something on CNN and you wonder why I
wonder if that's really true so I think
those two changes one of them
technologically-driven made the big
difference for Donald Trump so you look
at the situation now where he's having
poll numbers that are showing you with
lower approval rating again you have the
saturation by the media that's I think
pretty overwhelmingly negative about
president Trump's so far do you think
that still the media is having a pretty
big impact on his presidency right now
despite his ability to reach out to
people through these other avenues well
of course a lot of the polls that show
him with a low approval rating are the
same exact polls that showed Hillary
Clinton winning easily so their sample
is questionable one of the problems in
this campaign has been the polls across
the board were largely wrong some of
them I think through an honest mistake
others because they were padded
in other words they're based on an
assumption that the turnout this past
presidential election was going to be
identical to four years ago and the same
number of blacks and whites and
Christians and Jews and women and men
and younger and older and so on that was
a false premise there was an assumption
that Hillary Clinton would both pull out
the same number of african-americans and
get the same percentage of them that
Barack Obama got not possible so this
explains why the polls were so off there
was a antidotal
information to the contrary look at the
crowds Trump was drawing now look at the
crowds Hillary was having trouble
drawing look at the overwhelming
presence of Trump supporters and social
media the media tended to discount all
that counting on the pollsters so
perhaps the president's approval rating
is higher today than some of the polls
are showing on the other hand the
negative barrage does continue and it's
incumbent on the president frankly to
out communicate his critics he still has
the bully pulpit and he can still do
that can you talk about your early
introduction to President Trump and you
talked about in the book how you saw him
as potentially becoming a president
someday a very long time ago can you
talk about what that what happened there
and where you got that feeling the first
person to imagine a trump presidency was
not me but was former president Richard
Nixon I was working for Nixon doing
political chores in his post
presidential years and he met Donald
Trump in George Steinbrenner's box at
Yankee Stadium and they hit it off and
he called me the next day and he said
well I met your man I got to tell you
he's got it he couldn't really go all
the way he said that
and and then days later he dropped a
note which I reproduce in the book two
to Donald Trump that said
this is so typical of Nixon's circum
location mrs. Nixon he said saw you on
the Mike Douglas Oh show and thought you
were superb and she says if you ever run
for public office you will win because
you're a winner and mrs. Nixon knows
about these things so well of course he
was talking about himself in his own
judgment not long after that President
Nixon and down from spent a weekend
together
they went for a charitable event in
Houston Texas
they essentially barricaded themselves
in a hotel suite and spent hours
together talking geopolitics and Nixon
said Trump just fired questions at him
one after another wanting to know about
Brezhnev about the Russians the Chinese
really around the world tour so the men
hit it off and it was Nixon who first
saw the potential for a trump presidency
I wanted him to run as early as 1988 I
was determined of his presidential
exploratory committee in 2000 I was a
consultant to his exploratory effort in
2012 but in retrospect 2016 was the
right year why is that
well I think it was the perfect storm I
think it was not only the tipping point
had been reached for alternative media
as we discussed and that's an important
factor but also after eight years of
Barack Obama the American people were
really ready for something different in
the 40 years I've been involved in
politics I've never seen the voters in
this angry or this sour were this
disillusioned mood they're just totally
fed up with politicians political
institutions big media big government
they're ready for something radical
ready for an outsider and Donald Trump
fit the bill perfectly did he discuss
with you his plans to run this time
around before he made the decision or
how he was trying to weigh whether to do
it or not yes
within days of Mitt Romney losing but
before the end of 2012 Donald Trump had
his attorneys go to the US Patent and
Trademark Office and trademarked the
slogan make America great again
told me on New Year's Day of 2013 that
he was definitely running in 2016 and
that he had taken these steps at the
trademark office I was certain that he
would run throughout the entire year and
therefore the media columnist slike
McKay Coppins for example and others
this constant hectoring that crumpled
never really run he's just burnishing
the brand this is a publicity he's a
publicity hound this is a head fake I
knew through the entire year that he
would really run what was different this
year though because he has thought about
it before not carried through I think
his business was in the right place he
was in the position to turn over his
business to his older children I don't
think there were any more mountains to
climb in the real estate industry he'd
really kind of done it all with the
hotel now in Washington DC being a new
crown jewel and the Trump enterprises he
realized that that the country was also
in the right place I would go back to
something he told Oprah Winfrey 20 years
ago when she said Donald do you think
you'd ever run for public office would
you ever run for president and he said
no I don't think so
unless things get so bad that I have no
choice remember that interview that's
where we are today he's not running
because he wants the title he's not
running because of the great house and
the great plane you got he's already got
a a great place in in Manhattan and a
great place in Palm Beach he's already
got an airplane that's on a par with Air
Force One he's not doing this to be
somebody he already was somebody when he
ran for president he's doing it because
the country is in trouble and he thinks
he can save it what do you make of the
response to his presidency by the people
who do not support him the protests have
trickled down even to the local level
for state representatives who are not
Democrat what do you make of the
response the big protest that took place
right after the inauguration and what
does that mean for his success as a
president is a way they can just
permanently hobble him by
just trying to obstruct at every turn or
should they have a greater voice because
the popular vote went to Hillary Clinton
what do you make of it
well some of the demonstrations of
course are a get prop they're paid for
and orchestrated others I think are
sincere people who have concerns because
they may be buying the caricature of him
that has been painted by some in the
mainstream media the real answer for him
is pretty simple and that is you know
damn the torpedoes full speed ahead
fulfil your agenda if it restores our
nation's economic prosperity at least
moves in that direction you see an
uptick in jobs you've already seen the
uptick in the market you already seen
the uptick in small business confidence
but if he restores the economy I think a
lot of this will fall away a vibrant
economy would give him the revenues he
needs to address all of our other
problems focusing particularly on
infrastructure Trump is first and
foremost foremost a builder mm-hmm which
is why don't try to convince him the
wall can't be built because it can don't
try to convince him that our inner
cities can't be rebuilt they can if he
will fulfill those promises I think a
lot of this opposition will fall away
it's a tough wish list though because
you need the cooperation of Congress
where you have a lot of Republicans who
are deficit hawks and don't want to run
up a big tab on all these projects which
are going to be very expensive they've
also got healthcare reform tax reform
two major agenda items that you normally
don't see happen even in a single
Congress never mind two big items like
that so he's promised a lot to the
country do you think that he can deliver
and is there any you know hazard for him
having promised so much and then perhaps
not being able to check off every item
well this is precisely why he's using
the executive orders to achieve as much
as he can before turning to a
legislative solution his ability to
circumvent the Congress and go directly
to the people I think is unprecedented
since Ronald Reagan did exactly that
with the Democratic Congress but passing
his initial tax reform I do
the president should focus on tax reform
particularly his corporate tax cut is
across-the-board tax cut his program for
inversion I would do that first rather
than dealing with immigration first
because I think that is the the key to
the solution of all the other problems
he's going to have a tough road because
as you point out some Republicans in
Congress are in transient but his
ability to make them feel the heat if he
can't make them see the light by going
right to the people I think is still his
whole card let's talk about the book and
how you came up with the idea for it the
timing of it sounds like you had to
write it pretty quickly when did you
first decide that no there was going to
be a book about his election well I
decided to write a book at the time I
left the campaign because whether or not
he won or whether he lost there was a
book in this frankly I was pretty
confident that he would win through most
of the campaign even in the darkest days
because I noticed his resilience in the
polls in other words let's take for
example his attack on Senator McCain
when many in the mainstream media
thought that was it he was going to be
blown out of the race sure he went down
two or three points and he bounced right
back up same thing happened when he
attacked the judge who was of
mexican-american heritage he took a
small hit in the polls but he bounced
right back I think that's because voters
had bigger issues in mind and they were
going to excuse him these detours if you
will because of his overall agenda so I
think that resilience always indicated
to me that he could win a close race I
didn't think he had to expand the map
and that opportunity came late but it
came the ability to go into Michigan and
Wisconsin and double down in western
Pennsylvania was where he won this race
I go a step further he got approximately
3 percent more of the african-american
vote than Mitt Romney doesn't sound like
much sounds de minimis
it's the difference between winning and
losing Michigan she also got less
Hillary Clinton she got she got less the
overall turnout was not as great and he
got 3% more that's the difference
between victory and defeat in Michigan
that's a difference between victory and
defeat in Wisconsin and that's the
difference between victory and defeat in
Pennsylvania just that small incremental
bump up in the african-american vote so
you're in a situation where the race was
so close you can't point to any one
thing that made the difference because
it was so close it was a confluence of
things that made the difference
including his superhuman physical effort
in the clothes
I mean stealing a page from Harry Truman
he barn storms into eight states late
while Hillary Clinton is back in
Chappaqua or pyjamas looking at the
swatches for fabric for the new curtains
in the Oval Office they were very
confident the Hillary Clinton campaign
that they had a victory in front of them
and there were a lot of people in the
media people in Congress people
political observers pollsters who felt
the same way you are among a few who
felt confident that he would win talk
about when you really felt that the tide
had turned for him right before the
election well prior to the FBI director
announcing that he would reopen the
inquiry into Hillary's emails which I
think was the Thursday before the
election he was already gaining at a
pretty fast clip that event merely
accelerated his climb in the beginning
she was sitting still in the polls that
I was tracking but after that she began
to drop slightly that's where you could
see the trajectory so if the close of
any race when you're examining the polls
it's not where you are that's important
as much as of the direction so for
example if Wednesday in Pennsylvania
you're down five and Friday you're down
three and Sunday you're down one you can
see the direction in the trajectory all
of the polling that I examined the final
weekend which came not only from the
campaign some but the campaign did not
spend extensively
I'm polling whereas Hillary Clinton
polled every time she burped to test
that burped before we did it
but looking at polling from the state
Republican operations looking from
statewide candidates who were polling
the presidential question looking at an
enormous amount of data be claimed to
became clear to me on Sunday before the
election his timings perfect his
trajectory was almost perfect and he was
on a track to win I became confident at
that point nobody was expecting though
the victories in Wisconsin in Michigan
in Pennsylvania those three were really
considered outliers for him to be able
to pull off were you surprised though
that he was able to get those three
states no because you could you could
see in the polling that they were within
reach you could see that he was gaining
but also he visited all three I mean he
went back and visited all three in the
close where I think Hillary and her
folks must have thought this was in the
back and there were people who thought
that he should have been in Ohio that he
shouldn't have been trying to expand the
map he should have been focusing on the
must-win States what happened at that
level for them to decide to go ahead and
expand rather than just focus on the
areas where he really needed to win by
eventually one like Florida and Ohio
I think Minh was made that they were
both safe and that turned out to be
right Ohio particularly is interesting
because Mitt Romney and John McCain for
that mornin matter George W Bush spent
tens of millions of dollars and put
forward a very strong effort and none of
them could ever pop Ohio but that's
largely because in the western part of
the state Donald Trump was able to pick
up white moderate working-class Union
Democrats at a rate that neither of
those gentlemen any of those gentlemen
had been able to achieve so Trump pulled
out to about a five point lead in Ohio
and it never dropped Ohio was safe for
him much earlier I really didn't in the
end wasn't a battleground state Florida
was tighter but I think a good decision
was made that the Donald Trump would
carry both in their court therefore he
could afford to spend his time in
Michigan and Wisconsin in Pennsylvania
which was absolutely necessary
he could have carried Ohio in Florida
and still lost without those and of
course Virginia I think was always
winnable I think the Republican National
Committee pulled crucial resources out
of there the end which was detrimental
he could have won Virginia which of
course he lost very narrowly you break
the book down into various sections as a
campaign first the primary and then the
general election and you talk about it
requiring sort of two sets of staff for
each depending on you know what the goal
they wanted to achieve so that's a
little bit different how that sort of
transition from primary to general
election and you saw one top campaign
staffer leave and another one coming can
you talk about how that worked and a
little bit unusual and it certainly
worked in his favor
well don't from decided on a all
communications based strategy early on
in which the rally was the centerpiece
so he made a decision rather than
spending money on paid media he would do
every interview he could possibly Jim
into his schedule and he would go into
the states do these massive rallies
confident that the two cable networks
would cover them wall-to-wall and they
did it's a multi-million dollar campaign
commercial what do you think about it he
did this eschewing organization and
structure and of course while his
primary opponents were spending a
fortune on analytics and phone banks and
polling an organization Trump was going
solely communications and it worked he
so completely dominated the free media
before each primary that it was like
having paid advertising and that worked
fine for that portion of the campaign
when he hit Wisconsin and then
substantially subsequently lost delegate
contests in North Dakota Colorado and
Louisiana was stolen out from under
different formats that a different
format and you were heading into a
convention now in a convention there's a
premium on organization in structure so
for example no one in the Trump campaign
had thought about
who from each state was going to sit on
the rules and the credentials committee
which are crucial
if the nomination was going to be stolen
from from that's where it would happen
that's why I thought he was wise to
bring in my former partner Paul Manafort
who's an expert in convention politics
pulled together a structure ultimately
route the Cruz people and the Rules
Committee we were prepared to route them
and the credentials committee senator
Cruz who ran against us Trump in the
prime Last Man Standing so the campaign
needed to change at that juncture and
then it did then in a general election
the campaign needed to change again the
president wisely brought in Steve Bannon
Kelly and Conway and I think that they
were able to retool in time for a
general election campaign but that said
I can tell you
Donald Trump didn't prepare for any of
these debates not in the traditional way
with a stand and acting like Hillary
Clinton he knew he didn't do anything he
just he just read and made notes and
calculated anyone in and I would argue
he won every debate but there's there's
lots of criticism about his performance
that he did not seem prepared or
knowledgeable about some of the issues
he he's a polarizing figure there's
always going to be criticism I the proof
is in the pudding he won the election I
thought one debate you could argue was a
standoff the others which one was that
which to me I think it was probably the
first one the second one frankly he
clinched the debate when she said we
can't trust a man like Donald Trump to
run the Justice Department and he said
because you'd be in jail that was the
beginning of the end well nowadays the
criticism of Trump again is that he's an
outsider and he doesn't understand the
issues because he's never been in
government before people saying well
look now you've got an outsider here
he's doing all these things that maybe
not be good for the country because he
doesn't understand what do you make of
that criticism and and do you think
Trump really can learn on his feet in
Whitehouse well that's very typical of
the Washington establishment it's like
mr. president now that you're here you
have no experience in these things let
us help you what they really mean is let
us derail your your program the
Republicans in the Democrats the elite
leadership of both parties they like the
status quo they like the way things are
right now they fight on television then
they all go out to dinner afterwards and
slap each other on the back it's all
about getting reelected and raising the
money to get reelected my real problem
with the Bush Clinton Bush Obama
continuum is not only had they driven
the country into the gutter not only had
they given us endless war and massive
debt and spending erosion of our civil
liberties an immigration system that
leaves our neighborhoods unsafe trade
agreements that suck the jobs out of the
country and an incoherent foreign policy
but they and their cronies have gotten
extremely rich while doing it so while
they have made the people poorer and
less safe they themselves have made
hundreds of millions of dollars
it's an elitist phenomenon I think the
voters are fed up with well yeah Trump
is receiving a lot of criticism about
whether there could be conflicts of
interest for him because he is supposed
to be hands-off with his real estate
empire but there's questions about that
how do you think that will play out do
you think that the public may start to
scrutinize him in a different way and
think well wait is he you know is there
a conflict of interest here or do you
see any problem there with I'm not
selling every sexualy think one of his
greatest strengths in this election was
his independence the fact that people
felt he had so much money that you
couldn't buy him you didn't there was no
use in trying that he couldn't be bought
and he couldn't be bullied I think
that's still the case I'm satisfied with
the way he's structured his business I
think people are gonna be hard put to
find any actual conflict he I'm sure
understands that after he leaves office
he'll have many opportunities if he
wants to make more money but he's a
billionaire how much more money does he
need the important thing is
with that comes the independence to do
some very difficult controversial things
people who talk about his re-election I
think no I don't see that as a foregone
conclusion he may choose not to run it
depends on how much he achieves in four
years how much is left to be achieved
what do you think would influence his
decision to not run a bountiful economy
the return of prosperity but that's the
success in winning what we want to keep
doing it make it may take eight years it
may take four but he's a man of action
he's not going to sit back and let
somebody else set this agenda he's going
to set the agenda I think I'll decide
about re-election based on how much he's
gotten done how much more he has yet to
do he's given up an incredible lifestyle
to do this I mean here is a guy who
loves his family loves his grandchildren
he is really a homebody even when he's
in New York or or Florida he's not out
on the party circuit he loves to play
golf
he loves his daily routine there's a
huge sacrifice in this for him just in
terms of lifestyle he's doing it again
not because he needs to be somebody not
because it solves his ego but because he
has an agenda to save the country one of
the hardest parts for transition is to
take your campaign and then transition
into a presidential team he brought
along with him Steve Bannon who you talk
about the book as someone who was needed
to come in for the homestretch of the
general election and to keep Trump
focused and centered
yet now Bannon is sort of criticized and
ridiculed by you know on Saturday Night
Live they depict him as the grim reaper
that he's some you know outlier force
there in the White House that shouldn't
be there you know what do you make of
that criticism and what is how does that
square with what you know about Steve
Bannon the personal I think the idea
that been in is Trump's brain or Trump's
Svengoolie is exactly backwards really
in and that's because you've known him a
long time and so what Steve been and
and Donald Trump have the same worldview
that they are copacetic on issues is not
surprising that's how they became
friends that's how they were attracted
to each other so krump is not doing
Banyan's well Benin is doing Trump's
will he's doing the presidents well they
haven't done anything that the president
hasn't talked about in the campaign
Reince Priebus on the other hand you
know represents establishment
Republicans I am disgusted by the leaks
coming out of the White House I mean I
understand leaking I've got a fair
amount of it in my day
strategic leaking for a purpose but when
you are leaking to the detriment of your
boss when you are leaking for example
the Washington Post had a leak in which
a White House staffer says the president
is like a clueless child and the New
York Times had a leak that talked about
the president wearing a bathrobe in the
family quarters after hours which I
would hope so because it's pretty drafty
mm-hmm that's not helping the boss that
that's trying to aggrandize yourself by
leaking with and suck up to reporters
leaking I think it comes out of those
who are not Trump loyalists I tell you
this they're not coming from Steve
Bennett or Kellyanne Conway
because they are Trump loyalists so I
fear these leaks come from the
establishment Republicans who seem to
dominate most of the Washington most of
the White House staff under Reince
Priebus and their detrimental their
unprofessional and they're hurting the
president's not good hmm what do you
think's going to happen though because
he's going to have to work with
establishment people in the White House
with him I mean they could just undercut
his entire presidency then with leaks
and just lack of cooperation what do you
think needs to happen the best possible
reason to hire Trump people for key
positions people whose loyalty is to
Donald Trump people who supported Donald
Trump for the nomination prior to the
convention not after there are many many
qualified people who were active in this
campaign who have applied and heard
nothing being this enormous rush to hire
a Republican National Committee alum I
think it's a mistake
it is interesting to me that when Jim
Baker who was George Bush's campaign
manager was hired to be President
Reagan's chief of staff the first thing
he did was reach out to high-profile
Reaganites like Lynn nob Seeger and
faith Whittlesea and others and hire
them for the White House staff and
therefore he didn't Brook the kind of
criticism that you have now of mr.
Priebus so you've worked for other
presidents including Richard Nixon could
you talk about the two and if there's
any you said that they spoke at one
point in and while he was living can you
talk about any comparisons between the
two and how they operate it's pretty
early days and Trump's presidency but
there any similarities or differences
you can talk I think there's enormous
similarities between both President
Trump and President Nixon and President
Trump and President Reagan they're
different in the case of of Nixon both
men are brilliant both men are stubborn
when they focus on a goal you can't get
them off of it both of them are
pragmatic Trump is not an ideologue he
is a conservative populist or a populist
with conservative instincts but above
all he's interested in what works he's
interested in solutions kind of like
Franklin Roosevelt I think he may try
something if it doesn't work he'll stop
and try something else until he solves
the problem so I think they're both
they're both pragmatists and they're
both realists on the other hand Trump is
very much like like Reagan in in terms
of his size I don't mean just his
physical size although they have that in
common both tall and broad-shouldered
but there's a command presence there
it's it's more than charisma it's more
than magnetism but both men fill a room
they have a certain stature that is
particularly strong on television so in
that sense I think Trump is a master
communicator as Reagan was Trump is more
interested in the details
than President Reagan was in that sense
he's more like Nixon so I like to think
that he embodies the best qualities of
both that's very interesting so if you
were
make a call on his performance right now
what would you recommend to him in terms
of if you're on staff but what you what
you would what changes you would make or
what you would like to see him do
differently well stick to the agenda
which he's already doing not different
hire more Trump bytes I think that is
important that invest your confidence in
people who share your vision don't hire
people who have a great resume but have
never stood up for trumpism and weren't
for you in the general election I think
that's generally good advice and ignore
the the carping of the washington press
corps they're never going to get with
the program they're still in shock about
losing the election and don't forget the
alternative media in other words if you
want to reach millions of people
unfiltered interview with Breitbart
interview with The Daily Caller
interview with Infowars they're reaching
millions and millions of people and
you're not going to get the you're not
going to get the the twist that you'll
get from say CNN should he try to reach
out to the people who voted for Hillary
Clinton because she did win the popular
vote is there some way he's trying to
reach out the best way to reach out to
them is to revitalize our economy and
prove your critics wrong something that
Trump said throughout this campaign
where he would say in a year you'll see
you'll be really happy I'm going to do a
good job I think that's true I think
that he will get a reassessment after a
year so ignore the carping ignore the
petty criticism and stick to your agenda
and remember if you revive the economy
if you renegotiate the trade deals if
you start to rebuild our inner cities
just a one city as an example take
Detroit or Philadelphia and show what
can be done I think he could be one of
our greatest president does he have the
skills to take his business acumen and
then translate it into working in
government such a different skill set
you would argue I suppose ken do you
think he has the ability to do that he's
been a businessman his whole life the
master nations of Washington it's much
different having to work with Congress
there's lots of roadblocks and frustrate
you could say well gee see you need to
be a talent like LBJ to be able to work
with the Congress these days everybody's
so angry at each other right yet he has
none of that experience do you see him
being able to do that yes because he's a
deal maker he's a negotiator and you
never know how much of what he says is
for the purposes of negotiation so for
example he's talked about tariffs on our
trading partners I'm not sure he's
really going to do tariffs but I'm also
not sure that he's not it's the stick
now the carrot so either we make a
better deal or I'll be forced to do
tariffs he's doing that so far with with
various but he's but he knows that the
cut in the corporate tax rate would
[ __ ] China and Mexico faster than any
tariffs which is why he needs to put it
in forefront of his program the way he
has worked in the phone
I'm carrier for example and other big
companies to induce them to stay here
it's really worthy of Lyndon Johnson he
really has been jawboning these
executives to get them to stay and
expand I think you're gonna see more of
that now you can argue oh it's only a
thousand jobs here and a thousand jobs
there it's symbolic that he's making the
effort I think is what's important one
of the more interesting parts of your
book is where you talk about him as an
underestimated candidate I mean it was I
guess you could say it's the
understatement of the year he was such
an underestimated candidate how did he
stay confident but I was always amazed
by how confident he remained even though
you know you're right the Washington
media establishment his own party
everybody seemed dead set against him
being the nominee and then dead Sun set
against him being the president I mean
he just seems like an almost impossibly
confident person did you notice that
about him and how do you think that that
played into his victory well he's an
optimist mm-hmm
and he is supremely confident I think
that's one of the things that appealed
to voters um he is a can-do guy he
doesn't think that anything is
impossible we never thought that this
election was impossible even he at the
end I think finally got beat down by the
constant mainstream media saying you
can't win you can't
you can't win while he told his wife as
he said publicly baby we may not win
tonight that's about as bad as it got I
think it was momentary nobody could be
immune to the fact that the mainstream
media tried to write him out of the race
at least three times at the end of
August they were saying his victory was
impossible we hadn't even had a campaign
yet so I don't think he ever lost the
faith I always thought that he thought
he would win his confidence is integral
to the makeup of his personality that's
what makes him Donald Trump well where
does it come from you know that's
nothing unusual to be that confident
well I think two things first of all he
has succeeded beyond his own wildest
dreams in terms of building a a you know
an economic success a business success
but also the experience of coming to the
brink of disaster and fighting your way
back that makes you stronger Trump is a
very very tough guy what faizon what are
you talking about that the broad his bet
his bankruptcy okay take it back his
near bankruptcy he never filed for
personal bankruptcy he used bankruptcy
as a legitimate tool for his companies
and of course they emerged from
bankruptcy so he got overextended there
was a crash he survived it not only did
you survive it he came back stronger
than ever 1997
yes roughly this is very much like say
Richard Nixon and Watergate his career
is in tatters but he clauses out his way
back to respectability and he ends up as
an advisor to President Clinton on
matters of foreign policy that you know
are vexing the country Russia China and
so on so that near-death experience
makes you tougher anybody who doesn't
understand how tough Donald Trump is
really doesn't get it in his personal
demeanor he's very likeable he's a
regular guy he's not snobby or stilted
or stiff or formal in any way so he's a
billionaire who's not an elitist who's
not a snob but I think that experience
of coming close to financial disaster
and surviving it
has just made him stronger and more
confident talk about your book your your
relationship goes back decades can you
talk about your first meeting with him
while your impression was when you first
met President Trump sure I went to New
York in 1979 I was assigned to run New
York New Jersey and Connecticut for
former governor Ronald Reagan's campaign
I was introduced to down front by his
attorney the notorious Roy Cohn I went
in saw Cohn and I told him you know I
needed headquarters a Finance Committee
volunteers telephones and so on
and he said what you need is Donald from
now I'll make an appointment for you at
Donald Trump but he's very busy he's not
going to give you much of his time so
make your pitch and get out there's the
you know so I went to see Donald he was
very gracious I said mr. Trump it's a
great honor to meet you he said please
call me Donald after the inauguration
when I said congratulations mr.
president
he said please call me Donald he's an
unassuming guy he's just eminently
likable he has a great sense of humor
he's very funny but what impressed me
that day was his intensity he listened
to everything I had to say and then he
asked four or five very tough questions
and his questions and remember I'm
making the pitch that Ronald Reagan can
get elected president 1979 all of his
questions related to the electoral map
first question he asked me was how do
you get to 270 it's interesting I'm
assuming your man can carry California
which of course he did but how does he
get to 270 interestingly in virtually
every conversation I had with him about
the 1980 presidential campaign and he's
a junkie he loves politics the way he
loves sports
he would always ask that same question
at the end so give me your new take on
the map where's your 270 so he's always
understood that construct and I think it
was a key part of the strategy for this
campaign he always had an eye on how to
get to 270 electoral votes his politics
have been less concrete though
is considered at some phases in his life
to be a Democratic supporter no I mean
what are his politics I think people
still wonder where he is firmly planted
politically if anywhere well prior to
his political activism when he was a
businessman and strictly a businessman
he gave to both parties and he gave to
candidates from both parties not
uncommon many visits very common
particularly for people of his wealth
and with a company as large and with as
many interests New York City is a
Democratic bastion I one has to have
great relationships with the unions in
order to build anything in New York City
he's actually got a lot of Union support
he always had a great relationship with
the building trades unions he did leave
the Republican Party largely because he
objected to the Iraq war and he was
deeply disappointed in George W Bush and
I was there in those days he most
definitely opposed the Iraq war because
I was opposed to it and we talked about
it and I wrote that at the time he came
back to the republican party after
george w bush was gone he did briefly
switch to the Reform Party or actually
the Independence Party of New York which
is affiliated their foreign party
because Ross Perot and then Governor
Jesse Ventura urged him to look very
seriously at the Reform Party nomination
it's important to note that the Reform
Party was entitled to 58 million dollars
worth of matching funds at the time
something they're no longer entitled to
because of the strong showings of Ross
Perot in 92 and 96 so you had the
prospect of running for president on OPM
other people's money yeah that appealed
to trump the businessman as you might
expect but he correctly concluded after
a really intense exploration that the
country is not going to elect an
independent president anytime soon that
just ballot access is controlled by the
Republicans and the Democrats working
together and therefore one really has to
be a Republican or a Democrat to win the
election as president he switched back
to the party of his parents and the
party that he spent most of his adult
life
the Republican Party talked about a
little bit of the tensions within the
campaign this was dramatic moments early
in the campaign between Paul Manafort
who was the face to campaign person who
came in and Corey Lewandowski he was the
phase one person who was there
orchestrating the big campaign rallies
that really launched Trump into the
stratosphere as a candidate and how did
man afford how was he able to transform
as what you described sort of an unruly
campaign into something that had a lot
more discipline and and how do you carry
that out so quickly
and do you think it was you know
successful in your estimation and he did
win but there were certainly stumbles
along the way there in the second part
of the campaign well Corey Lewandowski
is an advanced man mm-hmm
and for that period of the campaign
that's what was called for Paul Manafort
was able to call on a deep bench of
political associates going back through
many presidential campaigns to lend a
hand people with more experience at the
state level he was able to pull the very
best out of the existing Trump
organization to whip together an
organization going into the convention
to surmount the challenges there it's a
substantial task but the successful
nomination of Trump quashing the Ted
Cruz forces in the Rules Committee in
their attempt to try to hijack the
nomination demonstrated that he was
successful also I think though the
convention has to be viewed as what it
really is a television show mm-hmm it's
about entertainment and Paul Manafort
helped Donald Trump stage a very
successful convention the highlighting
of the Trump children the terrific
speech to rally the faithful by Rudy
Giuliani general Flynn's speech there
are a lot of high points in this
convention we have a larger audience for
our convention than the Democrats
unheard of and they pulled it out they
pulled it together very quickly without
much structure so me and afford I think
and deserves and gets a lot of credit in
the book that's around the time that you
departed the campaign can you talk about
that a little bit and what led to your
leaving well I left in August because my
book on the Clintons was coming out and
I didn't want Trump to be accused of
being the secret you know progenitor of
that because he wasn't because I had a
fundamental disagreement on campaign
strategy at the time I mean I really
think I've already addressed it I think
he needed to run a more traditional
campaign and I did think that some of
the Twitter fights that he got in
distracted from his overall message of
immigration and tax reform and and trade
and so on again he was right and I was
wrong about a lot of it but I also
appointed myself as the number one
surrogate for Donald Trump I probably
didn't five six hundred interviews or
surrogate speeches between the time I
left an election day because I felt I
knew the man for almost 40 years and I
could tell people firsthand why he would
be a great president why I was forum
about his independence about his
resilience about his toughness so I
never stopped being a Donald Trump
supporter but at 64 years old I wasn't
going to be in a campaign structure in
which I had to approve what I was going
to write or say mm-hmm I felt I could be
of greater help from the outside and I
think I was during the convention there
was a dramatic moment when senator Cruz
did not endorse Trump on the stage he
just told the voters delegates to vote
their instinct or their conscience
instead of voting for Trump what was his
response to that and was that a surprise
to you I think it was a surprise to
everyone in the campaign because Paul
Manafort had made it clear to senator
Cruz and to Jeff Roe his manager that he
didn't have to use the word endorse but
he had to say that he was supporting
Donald Trump and the ticket this was I
think one of the great miss readings of
politics if senator Cruz thought that
Trump was going to lose and he clearly
did
the smart thing to do would have been to
do what Richard Nixon did in 1964 when
he was certain that Goldwater was loose
would lose give him a full-throated
endorsement and campaigned for him every
place that way if Trump lost people
would say good old Ted Cruz man he was
really there for the party he broke his
back for the ticket
he gets consideration next time instead
Ted Cruz decided to be Nelson
Rockefeller take his ball and go home
hardcore conservatives and Trump
supporters will never let him be the
nominee of the party because he turned
his back on the party when the prospects
didn't look good now later on when he
figures out that Trump is likely to win
he endorses Trump too little too late
senator so I think he made an enormous
mistake I guess he thought that the
quality of his rhetoric would be so
great that it would be like the 1976
moment when Ronald Reagan addressed the
convention after Ford's nomination and
it was true many people in that
convention hall said my god we have
nominated the wrong man he's not Ronald
Reagan in fact he's more like Richard
Nixon than Ronald Reagan what was
Trump's response was he surprised by
that hurt by it angry did he have any
wish I think he I think he was unhappy
but he was later on I think quite
generous towards the senator and I think
he accepted his later endorsement with
good grace too had gone back and forth
and traded insults there was Trump's
declaration that Ted Cruz's father had
been in conversations with the Kennedy
assassin and you write a little bit
about that in your book what do you make
of that it some people would say well
why are we talking about this it's not
relevant so but it you make it part of
your book can you talk about that a
little bit sure I believe that that
Senator Cruz's father did in fact know
Lee Lee Harvey Oswald Judith very Baker
who is indisputably an associate of
Oswald writes this in her book she said
it in multi
we'll interviews the photograph you seen
comes from the Warren Commission not
from the National Enquirer I think
Donald Trump threw it out there to get
under Ted Cruz's skin and make him erupt
that was not fair that was patriotism
when in fact no questioning his
patriotism was questioning his
temperament interesting look the
question is obvious why do people take
an instantaneous dislike to Ted Cruz
they're merely saving time so you feel
like Trump's tactics of trying to get an
emotional rise out of people on Twitter
should he do that now in the White House
or should he back off on that only for a
strategic purpose in this case he got
Ted Cruz so angry who was drooling you
can see him getting into a fight with a
ten-year-old boy in a rally so and the
kid keeps yelling lyin Ted lyin Ted
buttocks in a way you could argue
backfire because Cruz cited that as well
as I think there was some disparaging
things said about his wife Heidi as
reasons why he was not able to endorse
Trump and we could argue perhaps the
Cruz endorsement might have helped Trump
at the convention Trump won therefore I
think senator Cruz is the loser and his
entire calculation look he is a bush
Republican masquerading as something
else and and I call him out very
extensively in the book you think he'll
survive a 28 trying to run again in 2018
I would hope that somebody will
challenge him in the Republican primary
in Texas maybe the maybe the Attorney
General if not perhaps Alex Jones will
run who knows but somebody needs to
challenge him but if he survives that
and he has latent plans to run for
president I think many Republicans are
going to remember the fact that he
wouldn't endorse the ticket at the
convention you talk about some of your
favorite or most relevant passages in
the book that you find are you know work
really important to you that you want
people to take notice of sure Harry hurt
in his biography of Donald Trump and the
late Wayne Barrett who just passed away
recently the village
I've both written that a story that
circulated that indicated that Donald
Trump was scheduled to fly to Atlantic
City from New York and a helicopter that
would tragically crash in the Pinelands
and kill everybody aboard that that was
made up that Donald Trump never intended
to be on that helicopter that there was
no plans but that he promulgated the
story to generate favorable publicity I
can tell you firsthand that they're
wrong
BuzzFeed Harry hurt Wayne Barrett
because I was working for Donald Trump
as a lobbyist working on currency
transaction issues I was in Washington
he was in New York I called him and said
I needed to see him as soon as possible
to go over some compromise language that
needed an approval immediately and he
said I can't see you today I've got to
go to Atlantic City I said I could jump
the shuttle and be there in an hour and
a half it's really important he said all
right I'll send the helicopter ahead and
hard to come back and pick me up I was
sitting in his office when Norma Federer
his longtime assistant came in and told
him that the superintendent of state
police in New Jersey Clint Pagano was on
the phone he put the veteran cop on the
speakerphone and he said mr. Trump I
have terrible news the helicopter your
company chartered has crashed and there
are no survivors and Donald said are you
absolutely sure and Pagano said yes a
hundred percent and of course women were
crying there was a horrific time to his
credit Donald called every one of the
widows right then and there in some
cases breaking the news to them which I
could never have done so Donald Trump
was telling the truth now I am not
claiming that I saved his life
I really believe that this was an act of
divine intervention that this is bigger
than than any one person and at that
point I decided that God had spared
Trump for a purpose some future purpose
we know what that know what that purpose
is
very dramatic but Trump was telling the
truth about the entire incident and he
was smeared by his critics what a story
Roger stone thanks for being here to
make a to the president 2016 now
available delighted to be here thanks